[Music]  did you know that whale and dolphin  watching is sometimes not as  eco-friendly as it might seem on the  Canary Islands whale and dolphin  watching is a booming business with so  many companies competing for customers  some try to get as close as possible to  the aquatic mammals  but the noise is very stressful for the  animals some are hurt by ships  propellers do on the island of gamera  spanish company oceano takes a different  approach the team uses old fishing boats  that aren't as loud that allows the  animals to choose how close they want to  approach the trips combine public  education and research  [Music]  that way the company helps preserve  these fascinating creatures for future  generations  [Music]  like that  if you are also doing your bit tell us  about it visit our website or send us a  tweet hashtag doing your bit we share  your stories  you